so apparently Fast and Furious 7 is
still set to come out which is great
because that means I do not have to
stand in front of you right here right
now and go yeah brick mansions is Paul
Walker's last movie brick mansions so
brick mansions is an American remake of
a French film and in this movie Detroit
is just the worst city on earth in terms
of crime have you ever seen a movie
involving Detroit you already know that
so they walled off a complete section of
it like his Escape from New York style
that's where Crimea underprivileged folk
lives led by risen now they got their
hands on a bomb so now Paul Walker needs
to get inside Arkham City with the help
of this really athletic dude who looks
and moves just like Darth Maul and he
needs to stop it from getting wasted
this is like the reverse Elysium Elysium
dude on the lower level of society has
to infiltrate the high level of society
brick mansions indeed from the high
level of society has to infiltrate the
low level of society you get it this
movie started out I was like oh sweet
action scene this dude is moving like
crazies flipping up and around bars and
ladders I'm like this dude is badass and
this movie might just be cool then
immediately after that like a scene one
is over and I'm like alright I'm bored
and for a while in this movie I was like
it's okay though cuz this movie's gonna
get interesting if it's not interesting
all these things in this movie will make
sense you know like people with
automatic weapons will actually have
aims swear to God this one person could
be in the open 20 people with automatic
weapons just start unloading on him it
is just like and he lives through the
experience not even a scratch on him I
think this movie makes sense even at a
point this bond has like six minutes on
the timer it's almost like alright drive
this thing out of here get it to a safe
destroy it out of here there's six
minutes on the clock this thing's gonna
go thermal nuclear and [ __ ] no one can
drive a bomb to a safe distance in six
minutes that kind of logic is sprinkled
throughout the entire movie even risen
in this movie alright I don't want to
talk ill about how someone talks God
knows I know my voice irritates the [ __ ]
out of people but there's something
about the way he talks talks like Elmer
Fudd kind of he's my mom's ingredient
you know what I like about my mom's
ingredients that you can always get it
right you gotta be very very quiet when
you miss you didn't quit its war hunting
wabbits maybe it's a dick thing to say I
just there's something about him I don't
buy him as this huge mob boss guy he's
one of those guys just kills people for
nothing I know
movies have the bad guy kill their guys
for nothing just to prove a point to the
other guys like boom alright get it done
BAM because I say BAM so if you're a
boss and you do that and you're a big
dick and you're just killing your guys
for no reason whatsoever at a point
they're gonna be like wait a minute so
if I don't do what you say you're gonna
kill me if I do what you say you still
might kill I think I'm gonna kill you
yeah you don't live long if you're too
much of a dick I was hoping this movie
would be like Dredd where it's just this
kick-ass awesome movie proof positive
there is a difference between
entertaining action sequences and a
kick-ass awesome movie in the end brick
mansions had entertaining fight
sequences I really like the dude who
teams up with Paul Walker he's from the
original district b13 movie Paul Walker
was functional in the movie which is my
way of saying I want to say nice things
about him because he's just not with us
anymore but in the end he wasn't good in
the movie I know this may piss people
off with the fact that Paul Walker has
passed on rest his soul he still s the
cheesiest Lee he is belong to Keanu
Reeves at a point I was sick and tired
of hoping that the movie would get
interesting I just kind of fell into it
I was like alright let's wait for it to
end entertaining fight sequences
entertain me while I was waiting for the
end but in the end I was still waiting
for the end credits to come up so I will
say brick mansions yeah you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus one day he
already forgot
all right so brick mansions have you
seen it what did you think about it have
you seen the original district b13 and
is it better than brick mansions or is
it one of those foreign movies that
people love in America because it's a
foreign movie and it has really cool
fighting but in the end it's just
actually not better than an American
movie that has really cool fighting it's
the same thing anyhow whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]